everybody
my name is umesh fazirani and
i'm the research director for quantum
computing here at the simons institute
so
thanks thank you everyone for joining
for this science communicator in
residence presentation i'm supposed to
tell you a little bit about the about
this program so
uh you know the science science
institute uh science communicator in
residence program was created in fall
2016
with i guess dual goals of
increasing visibility of
theoretical computer science
and also supporting science
communicators uh interested in covering
the field
so
resident communicators participate in
the institute's
research programs
produce written and video content
about the research taking place
at the institute
and train our participating scientists
on how to communicate their work
to a broad audience so today today's a
event it's
you know we're really delighted to
have a current science communicator in
residence jordan
helenberg
so
he um
uh
you know jordan uh is is sort of unique
in the sense that he wears two hats he's
one of us uh in you know actually so
he's a professor of mathematics at the
university of wisconsin madison
specializing in
number theory algebraic geometry
with
additional interest in combinatorics
topology application of machine learning
to pure math
and then of course he's also an
accomplished
science communicator to a broad audience
he's the author of two popular books
on mathematics
how not to be wrong
and shape
and
many articles in newspapers magazines
etc
so um he's
uh
of course
finishing his residency here this week
but uh but he's going to tell us today
about outward uh facing science so
please
join me in welcoming
or coming in here
[Applause]
hi everybody thanks so much and thanks
um to the institute for having me here
which has been like a very uh
enlightening visit which i'm learning a
lot i've talked to a lot of people i
hope some of you i haven't talked to
i'll get to talk to over the course of
the next week especially as
uh this ai and humanity
conference gets underway um
this is going to be kind of an
experimental talk i have never
when i talk to people one-on-one about
science communication a lot and i think
i have never
tried to talk about it in a seminar form
so uh
let's see how it goes but you should
feel free to
interrupt me you know i feel like
the talks i've been to it's work so i
feel like theoretical cs is like a
little less of an interrupty culture and
pure math is like a little bit more of
an interrupted culture so i'm used to
people yelling stuff out like while i
talk and
we can feel free to do it math style um
because i'm interested to know part of
my ambit here i think is like
understanding
what you guys want to know
um about whatever expertise i've sort of
accidentally gathered about science
communication uh over the years so i'm
just gonna talk about stuff and then
let's see uh
where it goes
so i mean let's sort of talk about this
catchphrase outward facing science that
i want to kind of promote a little bit i
mean
okay we
complain a lot
about the way
the science we know is presented in the
media about everybody here has done that
at some point or another and i certainly
have and you know there's there's what
to complain about
right i mean my friends who are the
topologists like they're just like the
donut as a coffee cup people and like
number theorists like me are like the
finding patterns in the primes people
right that's what the world says that we
do and then maybe we're like
compromising your credit card by finding
a pattern in the primes or something
like this um
for a lot of the people here who work in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning um
i would guess and you could tell me what
you think that the level of popular
caricature is
even higher is that fair to
say i don't even know what's what's the
equivalent like what's the thing that is
like the most goat getting that you feel
like you always
see
what you described was
was a was it focus on a very narrow part
of the subject but there's also
distortion you know if i were to take
what's what's
i would sort of say maybe i don't know
the subject at all
and um
and if i were to judge the popular media
by what they say about one computing
i would i would actually doubt
everything else i read
maybe you should though
okay
yeah so i mean
[Music]
we have this experience of like
talking to the i mean
so it's not even just like that
somebody's writing something and they
sort of
read and sort of what they convey
doesn't really track what we know it's
even when in articles that where we
appear and are quoted still somehow
we're not so happy about the way things
come out so what i mean
by you know why don't journalists talk
about science as it really is because
they don't necessarily know how it
really is like that's not their job they
have a different profession and if we
want to add something to the public
discourse about science i think there's
no real alternative to at least part of
it being us telling our own stories
that's what i mean by outward facing
science like
us talking to the public
not through the conduit of a
professional journalist but um
but ourselves
um
that's what i mean by outward facing
science and it's something that over the
years i sort of accidentally have
learned how to do like over a long
period of time
and know something about and now i'm
sort of trying to share some of that
information and so what i want to say i
mean so what does that look like in
practice right it's nice to say
what does it actually look like let me
draw a picture of the way i think about
it
because i think there's a lot of ways
that we scientists convey
information and there's kind of like
the way i like to think of it is there's
a big curve
it looks like this where the axes are um
i planned this board very badly didn't i
okay well um i'll label this axis here
this is um
what we can ask
of our audience whether that's in terms
of amount of time or energy or attention
or whatever and then this is like um
number of people reach so the reach and
the size of the ask are kind of
inversely related to each other and um
a lot of what we do
as science communicators uh
is somewhere on this curve indeed
something that probably all of us do if
we're academics is we teach in the
classroom right and that is by the way
an essential part of our role as science
communicators and i think that one way i
like to think about
all this kind of stuff that i and other
people do is sort of as an extension of
what we do in the classroom
it's at a different point in the curve
but it's the same kind of thing so the
classroom is like
maybe over here
where you're talking to 20 or 50 or 100
or the cs professors i guess they're
teaching like 500 now right like the
giant
intro cs classes but sort of that order
of magnitude of people um
oh i messed it up i knew i was going to
do this
it's really more like over here right
few people reached
or you can always turn your heads 90
degrees
um fairly few people reached but we can
ask a lot right we can assign homework
and have tests and they're with us for a
whole semester um
actually i would put the terminus of
this curve is really i like to put even
like
phd advising that's one person
but you really get a lot right i mean
you can ask for a lot of their time and
like you're together for a period of
years and that's sort of what i consider
and then you know over here
is like
um
something like national tv something
that very few of us get to do um but if
you do it i've done it like a couple
times
maybe you get 30 seconds 60 seconds 90
seconds like that's what you get and
that's what you have to offer but the
reach is incredible
um
and then maybe and then there's like a
sort of huge range right i mean there's
i guess um i don't know if there's such
a thing as a viral
science tick-tock star there is such a
thing as math talk
i've seen it you get a little bit longer
than you get on tv and probably you
don't get as much of a reach tv is still
really big yes i i think what is missing
here is not just the number of people
you reach
but how much of the content that they
perceive
is the content you wanted to convey
that's true but to a first approximation
i feel like in some sense if we're like
delivering a certain amount of content
per second like there's there's some
first order where like the longer we
have with them the more we can convey
and i also think that
the more attention and time you have
like the more
you can refine your statement and sort
of make it closer to what you want to
actually understand about this in a
minute but i mean it's um
all right so these are the ends and then
replace um
there's like lots of stuff in between
here but i sort of want to talk about
like
maybe um
articles in the national press
are here
um
books are maybe here a book takes a
little bit
longer to read and like probably unless
you're
john grisham or something like that like
it's not going to be seen by as many
people as might see be seen by an
article in a major paper um but they're
kind of in this middle ground um
that doesn't mean they're the most
important
part of outward-facing science but it's
the part that i know a lot about so i'm
going to kind of focus on that
in today's talk but i think actually the
stuff that's in here like the people who
are doing youtube stuff and the people
who are doing which is like a little bit
shorter and less content but is i mean
or podcasts or like all that stuff is in
here and actually
i would love i mean we want to talk
about that we can talk about that too i
don't know much but i mean maybe maybe
uh some of you know more um
so
by the way it may look like i'm checking
my email but i just have my notes on my
phone because i'm fine not to like print
so much stuff out unnecessarily um so
these are my notes
um
i talked to a lot of people who are
interested in this like a lot especially
younger scientists
um
graduate students in postdocs and
you know with like the energy of not
having your life like already kind of
set out and you sort of already you know
at my age you kind of know what kind of
things you do
and the early career scientists are more
like figuring out those questions so a
lot of people like i can i can know just
from talking to people that there's i'm
not making this desire up that like a
lot of people maybe even some of you
since you've chosen to be in this room
with me today um are interested in
telling your own story so let me start
with a couple of questions that i'm
often asked number one question that i
am always asked is just is this actually
compatible
with moving forward on my scientific
career or would i be like screw myself
over
to devote any energy and time to this
and here i can sort of emphatically say
yes
um it is completely compatible with an
academic career because the truth is
that
what did that look like for me and what
might look like for somebody else it
looked like when i was like a graduate
student and a postdoc and even
a pre-tenured professor i would write
maybe
two to four
articles
a year that's actually not a huge
commitment an article of course is not
like an article like we write
for science an article is like
maybe a thousand words long like three
pages
it's not actually a huge
commitment
um and that's definitely enough to feel
like you're doing something
and just sort of build up
a repertoire
of stuff of course if your goal was to
have a career as a writer that would not
be enough
so i'm talking about for those of us
who's like our career is this
we're here we're writing papers we're
mathematicians we're proving theorems if
we're
engineers we're developing systems um
does this work as a thing to do on the
side it completely
does i mean
and if i'm honest
for most of us certainly for me and i
think for most people um
do you have two or more than two to four
things like you really need to say to
the public
every year like maybe
maybe not like maybe that's enough i
mean look let me put it this way if
you're a professional writer like look
at the people whose job it is
like once a week they got to have an
opinion
in the new york times
don't you always feel like they have
like more pieces they have to write then
interesting opinions that they actually
have and there's like a lot of recycling
right so we don't what's great for us is
that we don't have to be
that person right we're
our job is doing science um and our side
thing is communicating and that means
that we only have to write about what we
want to write about like something that
actually needs to be said and i think
writing at that level
is extremely compatible
um
with
well i always like to hedge myself i
should say with an academic career now
i would actually be very curious
are there people in the room who are in
industry and can speak to that because i
know we have like lots of people
participating in the conferences who
work for companies
any thoughts on this because i feel like
i always give us advice but i mostly
know like
people who are like
assistant professors
okay let's hold the thought we don't
know
yeah
so you know you have this trade-off and
i'm just thinking about something
slightly different you know
and i was curious where you place it on
this on this on this curve so you know
blog like say scott erinson's blog where
would you place that and
you know what role does it say oh yeah
that's great because that's a key part
of the ecosystem and i would put it um
i would put let's give him his own
dots
i mean scott is going to be a stand-in
for like
scott-like individuals maybe there are
no scholars
but yeah for those who don't know him
like he writes um a blog with like a lot
of really interesting stuff about not
just quantum computation although that's
sort of his research area um
and i would say
um
maybe i should put him a little bit
closer to books because the books itself
has like a very wide range depending on
what the book is like and just like
commercial factors that you can't
control of like there is a whole
spectrum there there's still colliders
yeah
a good idea of putting kill
should be we're just going to keep on
decorating this thing books is
books of the spectrum that should
actually
include this stuff right because folks
have a writer but i would say in general
i mean you can tell me what you think
but i would say for all of those the
blogs we named gil's blog luca's blog
and scott's blog
and terry absolutely if we're gonna
incorporate
math
and other stuff
um
it's it's certainly not the same as like
the washington post new york times
atlantic
slate kind of audience but it's more
technical than that it's a smaller
slice
um
but you can do more right scott's posts
are a lot longer than an opinion piece
in
the newspaper okay so i guess you're
saying there's a little bit of a
off curve question in it those are
shorter but
maybe aimed a little more technical on a
smaller okay so i guess it's not a
purely one-dimensional second cloud
ayate
so um you frame this in terms of perhaps
like the compatibility
of this kind of communication with that
academic career
perhaps there's also
um
a way to think about it as there's kind
of an imperative to participate in this
as part of an academic career as well
because
uh i don't know how it
works in various disciplines but of
course there's this imperative
and in different countries of course
towards things like impact
which uh in some disciplines may be
primarily
uh defined through things like citation
counts but it might be more qualitative
qualitatively assessed in other
disciplines where
communication to the public and maybe
the take-up of that kind of
communication in policy or or judicial
worlds is is highly highly valued and so
maybe like
there's a complicating
factor in your curve that's like yes
this this might be compatible but this
might be like imperative and then
what what what does that say about the
actual purpose of the communication
because you might even put like twitter
right on your on your curve
oh yeah i do that i should put it on
which isn't you know partially about
communicating things but also very much
about self-promotion
and so there's something there's like
yeah communication versus like
self-promotion and relationship to
institutional
may be complicated
yeah i feel like where you put twitter
and tech talk relatively on the curve
like basically the function of your age
right like oh twitter obviously but
probably not really anyway yeah so this
is okay that was a really interesting
stuff with a lot and some of which links
with stuff i'm about to say some of
which
doesn't and i want to speak to it first
of all
interestingly i thought you're gonna go
in a different direction with the first
thing you said when you said like well
to what extent is imperative i kind of
thought you were gonna say like to what
extent is it a moral imperative
so we may feel just internally like it's
important for people to know but i think
you meant more like an imperative in the
sense that something like your classroom
teaching that is actually considered
like part of your
job
so right because this is a good example
of something that
most of us don't get to pick whether we
do it or not like we just are going to
do it and the only question is whether
to do it well or poorly
um
here's what i would say the part that
was going to link up with something i i
was going to say but forgot to which is
like in terms of people's anxieties
about will this mess with my career is
that just as you say
um
writing for the public sort of
translates it to impact and like how
many of you guys have written an nsf
proposal
already
but it doesn't think i'm not
understanding it's like not
your nrc yeah
way to computer science not right nfl
proposal okay
um right so you know that there's like a
broader impact section and this stuff
definitely counts so it is i mean but i
wouldn't say it's an imperative because
nobody makes you have that particular
kind of impact so i would but i would
say it's definitely rewarded i would say
it definitely
so to speak
counts that kind of impact it doesn't
people who are in the institution don't
care if people get the right message
they just want the numbers yeah
and i mean there's you know it totally
depends but they're like these research
excellence frameworks that are nationals
sort of evaluation schematics in the uk
in australia that includes like
impact as criteria for funding
nationally
well so you're saying it's like less
loosey-goosey than in the united states
where like if you do it great and you
can get credit for it but nobody's
looking over your shoulder i have to
know that yeah actually this is really
interesting because it's true that
as an american i look at everything
through extremely myopic american lens
and so everything i say is kind of like
this is how it works in american
academia and american media you should
always like preface it because i'm
realizing that there's a lot i don't
know
well you know america from what you know
my my internalization of it managed to
avoid some of the like national
accountability stuff that happened in
the 80s and 90s because the institutions
were in
some of the institutions were wealthy
enough to resist
like the need to demonstrate
value for money in terms of research
funding
but that's you know so that that means
impact
means a certain thing and it's perhaps
also more about uh achieving profile for
individual researchers such as they can
get jobs because it's more competitive
versus uk australia for instance
i see so yeah it's definitely true that
in the united states i think it
certainly is like helpful for grant
applications but no one at least that
for a young american academic nobody at
your job is expecting you
to do it but i think what i evolve
another question i'm often asked is like
will the people of my job the senior
people in my department people deciding
my tenure will it be seen as a negative
like i'm not serious and there i would
say no not in the u.s academic
economy that's really interesting for
instance in england i know that um
marcus dusanto i know well i mean he is
a professor of like this in america we
don't have that it's like less
institutionalized there's no such thing
as being a professor of i forgot exactly
what his title is but he's literally a
professor of talking about mathematics
totally
um and we don't have i don't know if
that exists in australia
but it doesn't exist in the u.s um
okay sorry i'm just pulling up
my no it's um
yes um
so
compatible with it in certain ways like
helpful to and i guess in certain
national aspects like maybe even sort of
an expected part of an academic career
it's going to be like a lot of things we
do in science that um the more you do it
the faster you get at it so it sort of
becomes like a
easier and easier
go to the point of that now if i have an
idea for a thousand word piece that's
like an afternoon of work for me it
certainly was not when i started
but now it's something that i can like
roll out pretty
magazine ready copy um
in that amount of time and that just
takes like common experience um the
other thing i do by the way book writing
that's sort of a different
story and it involves a certain like
level of focus commitment that i think
is
um
like i didn't do this until i already
attended
and i'm not sure i would recommend it to
like what of my mentees
sometimes people have a book and then
they can't stop themselves but i mean i
would i would
i would maybe say this is like a later
career
thing to talk to although
um
but okay these are generalities but i
want to get even more specific i want to
talk about something new that i did this
past semester
um which is that okay so
i didn't say my own story
is that
i was a math major in college i was
always really interested in writing and
i went off to do um a creative writing
degree for a year so i spent the year
just like hanging out with writers and
like
um and i've been going to like a lot of
workshops and
well that life was not for me it has the
life has many flaws but i'm a writer of
literary fiction but um
one thing i i sort of came to i guess
what i'm saying is like
when i think about what good science
writing is and now we're focusing in on
like the written word as a means of
communication fundamentally i think good
science writing is good writing i think
the things that make an article about
are science
effective of course it should be
accurate right of course it should tell
the story we want to tell but
that's in some ways kind of a low bar to
clear
we have to write something people want
to read and for that i think the sort of
virtues of
that make science writing good are not
so different
from what makes an opinion piece about
anything else good or for that matter
what makes a short story good so an
experiment i wanted to do
and i wanted to do it for a long time
and i finally did this spring was to run
a writer's workshop
for scientists that would basically like
run along the same goal as
um the way creative writing workshops
work for people who want to be novelists
or short story writers
running in that same format uh to see if
it works and what that means i don't
know is anybody in the room taking a
creative writing course they're like
done uh
okay like one
yeah it's not that common they're pretty
popular courses at wisconsin probably
most us
universities um
so what that meant
and i wanted to do it this semester
because i felt like
i didn't want to restrict it to
wisconsin and i felt like probably
spring
2022 was like the last
semester people were going to be willing
to do a zoom class i was like i probably
can't get away with it like any time
later than this i wanted to do it kind
of globally so
um
so we got together over the course of
the spring um
and um and the way a workshop works is
just like everybody submits a draft of a
piece and then for each piece we just
spend the entire
hour
going through it and talking about
both how it's working globally but also
like individual words and sentences and
that's pretty deep an hour is actually
like a long time to talk about a
three-page
document
and the truth is like
we could have gone longer i would say
every week we could have gone longer but
even so an hour is a lot of time to
spend and it really allows you to go
pretty deep and so i'm going to take the
rest of our time together which is not
not that long um
and again people should feel free to
jump in
um
just to say some stuff that i learned
from this workshop because even though
i've been doing this kind of thing for a
long time it really helped sharpen my
own thinking about like
especially for like novices like what is
it
uh
that makes a short science piece work
and also sort of to be honest what
habits do we have to unlearn that like
make sense in our usual academic writing
but that don't actually make sense uh
in this context i think over time i've
kind of learned to what you know
what they call code switch
like i don't really think about it if i
sit down to write something that's not
academic i sort of
instantly slip into that different
register but for most of us like most of
our experienced writing is in
writing papers or most writing grant
proposals those are written in a very
different register it's just different
so
the first thing i'd say this is probably
the most important
takeaway
um
which is simply this that
in anything you write
you just ask
every single word individually what work
it's doing and then you take out the
words that aren't doing any work
that sounds like very simple but it's
actually we're not
we i mean okay there's probably people
here who do nlp and are going to laugh
at me for saying this but i feel like we
kind of look at sentences and even
paragraphs there's like big chunks we're
not sort of it doesn't come natural to
us to like look at every single word but
i think as a writer you do actually have
to
train yourself
to do that um
let me give an example this is actually
a lot of my students were
ml people so
some of the examples will be those kind
of examples hey ms you want to add
something you look like you're half
raising your hand you know
okay so maybe before we get i just have
a thought before we get to the world
yeah
you know so if you if you ever write an
article for science or nature
you go through a certain kind of
thinking you know that might you know so
you go through a certain kind of thing
okay i want to write this article but
but is it of interest to anybody and
what aspect is most interesting you know
why would it be interesting
to a to a wide science audience
and then you know so there's there's a
there's a process that one goes through
and and by the time you're done with it
um
you know you're still talking about the
same results but but uh but maybe from a
very different perspective or or
highlighting very different
parts of it so
so
i i was curious in this particular uh
exercise you did you know was there this
stretching of certain parts and
shrinking of others or
perspective and so on
this is a great question it speaks to
something what i'm going to say about
this it might be a little idiosyncratic
to me and not everybody would agree with
it because it's natural to approach this
and be like
well how can i make this interesting to
other people right what are they the
public the audience interested in how
can i sort of like change my vision so
it's interesting to them i don't
actually see it that way
um yeah but that's not what i meant
either okay
yeah i was trying to say not that
not that how do i take this and move it
to where it is but how do i how do i
take what i've done
and actually explore it from different
viewpoints until i find something that's
really fundamental there you know which
is which was which i had not put my
finger on before
i mean i guess what i would say there's
a tension there's attention because you
want to sort of as you say it's a
breakout of like your customary when i
see things at the same time in the end
i think it's okay
like to see it from europe to see your
own viewpoint in the following sense
like i feel like i mean it is kind of
sort of similar to like when we're in
the classroom
teaching calculus or teaching anything
else that we
teach um
that you have to like locate your own
excitement and be in touch with it
and convey
that
like i think it's important and maybe
this is this is like really like third
bullet point maybe i'll just like say it
first that
sometimes in academic writing maybe
always we're trained to kind of be a
sort of objective like voice from
nowhere
like that's the style even in math we
don't say
i on our papers you guys do that in cs
like we say we
as if we're speaking for sort of some
like
massive
vaguely human thinking entities but
definitely not like i myself i'm not
supposed to be like present in my
theorem um
in writing for the public it's exactly
the opposite
i think you do need to be there like not
like a lot like you don't need to sort
of like describe what you were eating as
you like thought about this project but
i mean um there should be some sense
that there's like another human being
who is telling you this like part of
that is like
um
if you are excited about something like
i think you can convey that and actually
if you're not i think
then it's very hard to do a good job
even if objectively you're like this is
important if you're not if you don't
personally have the feeling i think it's
extremely hard maybe it's like a level
of writing higher that i know how to
attain
to like make what's on the page be
exciting
if that if that makes sense but i do
think you're but you're right that's a
little bit overwhelmingly sort of a
little bit useful question of the
jumping off point
i think it's true
um
that
trying to break out of the way you would
ordinarily talk about it can be like
valuable not just for being able to
explain it but for actually yourself
sort of like understanding things from a
perspective
um
i think actually participating in an
exercise like the one that we did with
the workshop can be part of that because
one way i sort of get another point is
to literally be like okay the eight of
us are going to sit in a room whether
it's zoom or real
and really think about this thing that i
wrote
and we kind of all agree to share our
time with each other in that way so that
one week it's my week and that's like a
very direct and visceral way to kind of
see what you said from the outside
um
oh yeah i was just going to give a short
example and sort of say what i mean
about this first
uh
point ready so here's the sentence that
came up
i asked my student permission jesus um
uh you can't really i'm trying to
remember what
so this is this this is actually great
for the ai and humanity people because
it's a topic i don't remember what
particular model this article was about
but uh you can't really escape
the proliferation
of these models
in your everyday life there's a lot of
models about which you could imagine
saying this right people in the ai and
humanity
section but and this is like a perfectly
good i would say this is written in a
conversational register
but
if we actually look at it and like look
at each word and ask what we're doing
this is the kind of exercise like i sort
of tried to get us to do in a workshop
like this um
first of all
um
really is not really doing anything
really it's sort of like a soft version
of
sometimes it means kind of like very
it's like kind of an intensifier but it
doesn't add much semantic
to this sentence it's a it's something
we say in conversation to sort of soften
what we're saying to hedge and there's
often no need to do this in writing
so i'm going to cut it um
by the way sometimes it may seem
sometimes we talk about this in the
workshop a lot too that
there are of course no rules
so i'm not going to say like the word
really
can never be used of course sometimes it
can't it's just that it's often used in
this kind of soft way where it's not
doing much
and we just have to like um
get rid of it okay
so we can't escape
the proliferation of these models
you can't really escape the
proliferation of these models in your
everyday life by the way one thing i
like about this sentence i'll say is
that um
i said it's important for
it to feel like the author is present in
the piece it's also generally a good
idea for the reader to feel present in
the piece so this kind of language is
actually like
pretty good i feel and we wouldn't do it
in a paper
right you would never write this in a
paper but i think this
you might say it's a trick but it's more
just like a normal part of the way that
one human being communicates with
another and so i think this tends to
sort of be strong so i like this u we're
going to leave that in um
but
what is it that you're escaping you're
not really escaping the sort of rapid
growth and regeneration of the models
you're really escaping the models
themselves
in other words
we're sort of saying this sentence is
trying to do two things at once it's
trying to say
we're escaping
the models but then also that they're
proliferating quickly but i think it's
syntactically a bit confused
and i think we should just
cut
if we want to say the models are like
there's if we want to say there's like
more and more of them we can do that
somewhere else but somehow this is like
saying something that's not really what
we mean to say it's not the
proliferation we're escaping it's the
models we're escaping
okay and then finally
um
actually like
what's going on with
like where are you while you're trying
to escape
these models i mean i guess you're in
your everyday life but like
really where else would you be
like what does this actually tell you
about what's happening like
it does that it talks about
not just about your
work not just about your academic
research
right but then there should be an
example this is too big we can have
another sentence where and there should
be
where there's a thing
in your life that the models effects but
this i would like literally just
five and then do an example you can't
escape these models is what this
sentence really says
and like that's sort of an extreme
example but i feel like
almost everything
you write
you can go through and let's say like
literally cut out about 20
of the words and doing this like is an
immensely useful exercise because you'll
see that what's left is just kind of
snappier and sharper
and moves faster and i don't know it
feels like less
sludgy
somehow so we did like a ton of this i
mean this is that we
try to train ourselves to kind of all
uh do it
to each other's
work um
and in academic writing i think we don't
tend to have this as a value
right i mean for good reason it's not so
important but i mean we don't tend to be
like is every single word
super functional um you know i'll make
another couple points and then those
will sort of take questions and discuss
um
okay actually it's been different for
oh yeah okay i have another similar this
this will be the board where we sort of
attack individual sentences so here's
one that was uh
i abstracted from a student's paper um
one might
consider
and i forgot what the actual
things were in the sentence so i'm just
going to like put
variables in
x
to be a form of y this is kind of a
sentence you can imagine writing or
reading or seeing like in a paper but if
we take a moment to like look at
what it's doing
this is sort of what i mean when i talk
about this voice from nowhere
that we like to use in academic writing
because what am i really saying i'm
saying i consider x to be a form of y
but that's a little seems a little
aggressive i don't want to say that so
i'm just going to say some impersonal
one
you're saying that but i'm not even
saying that right that's even still sort
of seems too forceful so i'm just i'm
not saying one does consider it i'm
saying
one might in some counterfactual world
like maybe give oneself permission
whoever one is to do that um
yeah that's like natural academic speak
but it's like not natural for writing
for a general
audience this is like too
distant and it takes us away
it makes us not present like the author
the reader wants us to say something
yeah unless you want to follow this up
with like however
this is limiting for
some reason in which case you're
attacking this
broad viewpoint that some might consider
that is a great point right so sometimes
you raise
uh
the famous number theorist who sort of
he's like okay we introduced the
notation like so and so then he's like i
introduced this notation only in order
to object to it
and
so that's
okay so actually that speaks to another
one of my bullet points maybe i'll sort
of say now another thing that's very
natural for us to do in academic writing
sometimes because a referee has asked us
to is to sort of in our writing sort of
anticipate alternate or even opposing
views and address them
um
there are times when you want to do that
in popular writing but it's a little bit
rare
and so usually i would say um
like your readers are not going to put
your thing anticipating thinking about
like every possible objection there can
be sometimes there really is an obvious
objection that you have to address but
often it just seems like very fussy
if there's like multiple
uh
one bites so let's just say that in the
context this was not written this way
this was written as the person was gonna
endorse this view uh
and then
you know you can just say
oh you might probably i can't see it if
i write down here right
is this too far is this too low
okay
was this already too low
okay so let me okay we're gonna go over
here so
alternates for this you could say
um
let's put you in there
you can think
of x
as a y that's much faster and it says
the same thing
you might really need a form of but
usually you don't just depends on the
context but probably or even by the way
here's another option just
think
of x
as a y this is like the exact opposite
end of the pole where here we write it
in this kind of funny impersonal way
because we're like oh i don't want to be
seen as like telling you what to think
and here like you're really sort of
adopting the
what is this called there's a the
something mood the imperative mood
right where i the author
i am actually sort of telling you
what to think and sometimes we are doing
that so i mean depending on the tone
depending on the overall thing i think
either of these uh can work and they're
both snappier
than than
something like this which just comes
naturally to our hand
from academic writing
um
let me say one global thing and then
i'll sort of
oh yeah one more thing maybe i won't
write this one on the board i'll just
read it out loud this was one um this
was another ml paper um one of my
students wrote
this translation function is built using
a technique called contrastive language
image pre-training which has been
perfected and fine-tuned by many
different researchers in recent years
okay so
in academic writing
credit is very important right one thing
we really do not want to do is like
neglect to cite people that we should
cite
and this is one area i want to bring it
up because it's
it's an area where there is a real
conflict between our values as academics
and the way
popular publications work
is that if if you want to write a story
about a scientific advance where like
12 people were like involved in a
meaningful way
um
they're not going to let you put 12
names
in the piece somehow i mean this is a
constant source of conflict and i don't
actually have a good answer to how to
deal with it because i understand why we
want to give everybody credit and i can
also tell you that in practice
the editor is going to say like make it
about one person
right like we want to talk about
the model of sort of i mean i don't know
how to fight this but it's absolutely
true the popular model of science is
like
a person did something
and they're going to want to
have you focus on that person that said
this thing i just read you
i think falls in this kind of uncanny
value that you want to avoid where it
says where we i mean we do write stuff
like this on our papers which has been
perfected and fine-tuned by many
different researchers in recent years
all that says is like people worked on
it it doesn't even name them it's not
even doing the work of getting giving
the credit so i feel like there was like
a lot of stuff like that that we sort of
naturally write
that can just um
that can just be cut
um
so just to say
let me say one kind of global thing i've
said yeah
it sounds more like um i should ask by
the way when you ask a question i would
love it if you would like tell me who
you are because then i can sort of learn
like i didn't learn your name
your bot
got it okay
meal
maybe a lack of confidence so you're
trying to just justify what your claim
is by saying a lot of people are
thinking about it it doesn't matter who
they are i'm just going to tell you
they're credible researchers
to give myself or to give my prior
statement a little bit more lift
in terms of credibility and maybe
the point is that you actually want to
find a way to give yourself that
credibility naturally yeah that's a
great point that sometimes what looks
like what you write thinking you're
bolstering your credibility diminishes
it because it's someone specific that's
like right
it's a little bit like trumpian like
many people are saying right a very
common you can use that just some phrase
like it's i mean you know who who is
if they really are tell me who they are
so i know they're people i trust or not
you know
yeah that's a great point
um
so one just global thing i want to say
is that
a short article a thousand words is not
very long so i think one of the biggest
challenges you know as academics we want
our we want to be the completest in our
writing we want to sort of explain
everything
um
a thousand word piece
really there's room for one idea in it
maybe one idea with like a gesture
at a second and so i think one of the
things that we constantly had to do
looking at these pieces are said they
say
this is a great piece that's trying to
do three things because you have three
important points you want to make
and you just gotta write three articles
you can't do it
and like it's just it is actually a lot
like teaching if we like we may say well
it's just imperative that i cover like
all three of these topics and i have a
week left in class well guess what then
you're gonna cover zero of the topics
right you may feel like you covered it
because you said all the words
but in fact it doesn't work and i think
like the short
uh the short opinion piece
is like that too like much as it comes
natural to us we have a lot of knowledge
we have a lot to say we want to say it
all you do kind of have to pick one
thing and be like what is the idea
of this piece and if i get in and out
having done that then it's a success
um that also means that sometimes we
have to be selective about what we write
about i mean some i mean
because you may say well look there's
some
scientific topics some advances some
pieces of news that are simply
irreducibly complex and i can't really
boil it down to one idea those might not
be the right things to write about in
that format
sometimes the subject has to choose the
format i mean for me for instance
i mean there's a whole other story but
like i write a lot
about legislative redistricting and i
have written like thousand word
newspaper pieces
about that and each time there was like
a lot that went unsaid and i found
myself frustrated by the fact that there
really wasn't
i was able to say one thing about it but
there's like many things to say and so
that in the end i had to like
put in the book and be like it needs
like 70 pages doesn't need a whole book
about it but it needs like
a 70 page
treatment and in that case i think i
just think that the
the subject itself like determined
the format
um
okay that's a lot of stuff
um so let me close just by saying
i'll remind myself what it is that i
want to
close with um
sometimes by like going around and
talking about outward-facing science and
running workshops like this and my
desire by the way i mean this is my
overall plan i will
i would like there to be more workshops
like this
not done by me because i think that
there are a lot of students
who are interested in learning this
stuff and i think like a lot can be done
just by groups of people self-organizing
and reading each other's work carefully
and reflectively and looking at every
word i don't think there needs to be a
so to speak expert in the room
for this to work so part of the reason
i'm talking to you guys about this is
because i'm sort of hoping that people
will be like oh this seems like a good
idea like why don't we have this at our
home
institution
um but the end goal at least from my
point of view
even though i started by saying
we all like to complain about science
journalism and what we see in the
newspaper when reporters interview us or
interview our friends or don't interview
us or whatever it may be
um
i my goal is not to replace
science journalism my goal is to add to
it i do think we need to be able to tell
our stories like those of us who want to
those of us who have an interest whether
it's in a written format or a video
format or a blog format or whatever else
um
but i also think that
um
there's a role for actual reporting
especially where science intersects
policy there's certainly there's a lot
of stuff that i am definitely not
equipped
to do right i mean if you want to write
about policy you want
you need to know how to get a government
official to tell you something about
what's happening or how to find out
what's happening if the government
official won't tell you that actually
requires special skills just like our
stuff requires specialized skills um
that we don't have and we shouldn't
really try to do
probably so um
i see this work as
something to complement
the um
the pretty incredible edifice of science
journalism which actually is growing
like a lot and there's lots of room for
um that already exists um
so i'm gonna just gonna stop there and
take any more questions that there are
thank you guys so much for so many
people like coming to this
[Applause]
yeah but
uh
so
uh thanks for the great job uh one point
i had uh to ask your opinion about was
what you mentioned towards the end of
the talk uh
there is uh
editors have uh they like to attribute
uh contributions to one person
uh
which is
kind of not a very academic way of
writing
but it's also not a very honest way of
portraying uh
the
or attributing
contributions that people have made
so
how do you
reconcile with that and how can we
change uh the way this is done uh
because presumably uh editors are
uh
space constrained uh
for whatever reason but yeah but if i'm
honest with you i don't think it's about
those space constraints i think it's
about their view of like what works as a
narrative so that you're you can
probably tell my tone of voice when i
brought it up this is one of the hardest
ones for me because it's there's lots of
places where there's a tension between
the academic way and the
journalistic way and i'm just like well
if you're in rome you eat airport one
way and if you're in paris with your
pork a different way this i actually
kind of make more right about and so
it's like a little harder for me because
i sort of don't necessarily want to
acculturate to the
um i actually think it's sort of
the the stereotype of heroic science
where like
everything important like springs from
one individual mind is kind of like
bad for science so it's worth pushing
back against um
i don't know actually probably useful
for those people who do like
machine
one of the first long pieces i ever
wrote about press sensing during the
heyday of compressed sensing for wired
magazine and it was like really hard i
mean they really wanted to be like the
candace and tao show and i love the
manual and i love terry but they're not
the only people who work on it
but i was definitely kind of
made i think i wasn't even really i
don't remember what there was allowed
but anybody else's name but they
definitely were like already two people
is a lot they were paper together so
it's sort of okay
but i remember that tension being like
really difficult and because it's not
great it's not there is there's nothing
very little that important in our field
is like really springs from the mind of
like a single person or a single group
actually a comment on that and then i
wanted to say something
so the comment on that
on
worked well
in stories is uh is where the person
involved says
there was a there was an existing people
or something something that that softens
it and then then it comes across nicely
because the person is saying it
themselves
yeah they are acknowledging that they
were not
they didn't do this
so so that's just one thing but i i
wanted to make a
different comment
which was which was the following that
you know when we try to uh
try to uh place our own word within
within uh scientific context you know
within
uh
one way we can view it is that
you know we are
we are trying to connect what we've done
to the to the intellectual blockchain of
our fields and saying where does it
connect you know how low is the form of
complexity of what we have so how
significant is it within that
and
you know to to some extent
you know when i was talking about the
you know the science stage article that
that was the you know that was the sense
of it that you you really try to think
about what you've done and see where
does it connect
naturally
but now it seems to me that there's
there's also
uh there's also a
popular culture meme uh
uh blockchain right and and you could
sort of say where does
connect to it you know
by the way
i don't actually know what the
blockchain is
[Music]
or math or therapy
sort of thing here the big idea is now
do i connect to any of those is this is
this uh is what i'm what i'm talking
about is it is it related to one of
those or is it from this branch or
what's you know what level of branching
do you have to go out to before you can
place this particular advance or article
or something this idea you know where
does it where does it connect up and
what's the
you know what's the what's the thickest
branch if you want that it connects
you know so see if it's sort of ask the
same question about what you're what
you're writing about in the popular
person and you know there's sort of this
notion that well physicists are great
because you know
things connect to
you know what's what's the nature of our
physical reality or you know
you know black holes or or outer space
or you know what are the building blocks
of our office of uh space time or
whatever right so so it seems really
fundamental and you connect to that and
everybody's interested in reading about
it you know because because it seems
like
it's so important and then then the
question is that you know
uh you know
you know so so what what is you know
what is this thing that you're trying to
connect to and what's its nature
yeah absolutely and it's actually
that's a goal i mean that is an away
intention with the thing i said about
that in a short article it kind of has
to be about one thing because then what
makes it hard it's like how do you
contextualize it
and that really takes some delicacy i
mean i think often you kind of have to
do that in like a sentence or two at the
beginning you have to do it very fast
right because if you did it at the
length that we're used to doing it
academically the article would already
be over right if you were like
really put it in
the context of firework one thing i'll
say though is there's a shortcut so one
way to do it is what you just said being
like where's the trunk of science of
which this is a branch like what stories
is a part of but i'll just comment in
practice
certainly at least in my own writing um
there's a concept in journalism called
the news tag
and like what that means is like
sometimes people are going to be
interested in the topic like this week
because of something that happened that
they already
know about
like that like for instance like i was
the new york times written article about
kind of basic like
some kind of foundational questions and
like
bayesianism that's how i would put it or
like bayesian versus frequented
statistics but really what they were
doing is like oh they just ran a big
expose about how like two critics of
president trump were like audited by the
irs and a reportedly random audit like
in the same
year
and so there was this question like is
that unlikely right so of course the
content of the article is like it's an
article about probability
because like the question like what does
that question even mean and but there's
a reason they could run that article
that week they couldn't run at some
other they could run it because on the
front page there's this big extra say
about the irs and then it's tied to that
so that's what's called the news tag and
that's actually often a pretty decent
way
of thinking about
what to write about
like it's it's
it's maybe a little unsatisfying to us
because we're like we should like pick
what's most important and write about
that but like i think you do have to
kind of
be on a little bit of a sort of faster
feedback cycle like on grab
opportunities
to write about things when there's
something in the news that has energized
people's
temporary interests
um yes
okay so you can go and then
well you're calling sorry
one yeah so let's just sign with the ai
and humanism
so i have uh maybe comment on the
credential and i'm wondering what you
think about this like the hyperlink so
if there's a big paper you just put the
hyperlink at least that's what i've
tried to do but then my major question
is just breaking in because you it
sounds from this
topic follow the directions
the new york times are wired whatever it
is and they'll be oh how brilliant let's
publish it but it seems like the missing
part is how to break in so that people
are in your voice
and um i'm just wondering about those
steps
about breaking the tapes
yes i do have thoughts about that it's a
really important question and part of
the reason i didn't talk about it is
that i'm like almost too old to give
good advice about it because i know a
lot about how to break in
in the 90s
and the media landscape has changed so
much that that's like
almost irrelevant like obviously i used
to give
people um
right it's like oh exhibit articles here
local free weekly like okay that's going
on right that used to be a good way to
sort of get clips and like
um i'll say one thing so jake mentioned
uh twitter or other means of social
media self promotion that's actually a
great
way i mean sort of if you are
tweeting about stuff that's like
relevant to your science and if you
develop a certain following there i
think editors will like see that as like
they call it platform i'm telling you
like all the words that like people
journalism publishing like to use
they're like oh there's an existing
platform then okay there's at least like
a thousand people who already decided
that they wanted to sort of encounter
some words that i wrote
and that that i think is generally seen
as like um
a credential it's a weird kind of
credential i know but it's um
so that's one thing i would say
um
another thing i would say
is that um
you can use people like you can use me
or like other people who are already in
like i certainly for me like i've talked
to people where they're like
i have a specific thing that i want to
pitch and i can talk to them about where
i think that would go i did it with my
friend cooper berg
he published a thing about he thought
was a very
salty cranky quantum thing in slate
which was because he was like
jordan i've got to get out like my anger
about d-wave and i'm like okay this you
can run this in slate like send it to me
and i'll pitch it to that you know what
i feel like
um
so i mean i think
this is just getting bigger and bigger
there's like more and more scientists
who are writing and so i feel like
whoever is closest to you of course then
you know for somebody like me sometimes
i gotta say like no i don't think that's
gonna work
people i mean i gotta be honest
sometimes that's what i mean
because i feel like at this point i have
a pretty good sense of like what's
gonna grab and what's gonna not but i
mean
so that's another way too
um and probably
in the old day i mean maybe not in the
90s in the 2000s i would have said like
you know blogging like scott or gil or
luca does is like really good i feel
like vlogging has like receded a bit i
don't know maybe you're supposed to like
have a sub stack or something is there
like a theoretical cs sub stack does
that exist i don't even know
so
okay so i'm i'm so i'm slightly not
answering because i truly know less
about in 2022
um
but those are those are some things that
i
that i know but you're right that like
it's not just as much as like writing a
thing and then like mailing a few more
times i mean they get
thousands and thousands of
things every day and it's like um
uh yeah come on
thanks
i have i guess two
questions observations the first one
picking up a bit on what the stuff jake
was saying but we're from very similar
academic contexts
not originally in american content
and i'm interested in
i mean there's an overall question which
to me permeates sort of
editing choices and the whole thing
which is
why why do these it seems like you're
working with a model of
um
you're conducting scientific research
and there's an imperative to share that
this is a public function for that as
dave mentioned there are lots of other
reasons people might
uh
want to to do this and so i guess i'm
interested most of all i mean i've been
i've actually never done this but i've
thought about it constantly
since i observed this massive shift in
academia in the uk and australia and so
many people
really do mostly this in my view and
very little
of what i would call sort of deeper
deeper research work past a certain
point so i guess i'm mainly interested
in young uh people studying in the us
and what how they feel about this
whether this is something they really
they really want to do um
there's a lot of the word this and i got
a little lost so
are you literally saying that there's a
lot of senior academics in australia who
all they're doing is writing up ads for
the paper and they've given up on
research and they just like
pour out their opinions like are they
long for their job
i did not say that
i was careful not to say that okay so
i'm talking about a range of
forms of let's call them non-academic
uh
genres so we have to distinguish i think
between genre
and a whole lot of other questions which
i think
permeate the how as soon as you've
decided to communicate in this way about
your research or your area of expertise
there are a whole lot of health
questions which to me is part of my my
second question but i mean we can talk
about what that looks like in an
environment where we've almost entirely
shifted from
an authenticity paradigm of academia
which i think is still the dominant one
in the us
to a profilicity paradigm right so i'm
using a technical philosophical language
about self-hood and identity but
from an authenticity to a profiling
paradigm in the uk in the
neoliberal wash that's come through all
these you know right now this works
profile
so which is basically saying um
you're not only what your academic work
you're also what everyone thinks of your
academic work
and
you might read that as an imperative to
make people look at your work more
it's not but it's it's one of the ways
you can establish yourself and one of
the ways you can choose to navigate
through the academy right
so in an area where that has become a
kind of dominant paradigm these sorts of
imperatives but i guess i'm interested
anthropologically and what's happening
in the us because i see it as
qualitatively different as an
environment from some of these other
places
um can i guess also ring the warning
bell that i feel jake may have been
reading before as well to say
be careful of too much profilicity in
your
academic
identity
um yeah now you've thrown a scare into
me because i i must say you're
absolutely right that everything i'm
saying is in the context of this is
something that not very many academics
in the united states are doing and a lot
of people have told me that they want to
do and i think it would be good if there
was more of it rather than less but
you're saying there's like just another
equilibrium
i am saying that sounds terrible i am
saying that
these are people who are mostly
profiling and doing less okay that's
true it is dan ariely like a typical
professor at duke like obviously not
right he's like the one how about how
many psychology professors are there two
probably 50
and there's like one who does that
i don't know i'm estimating
i can't name any other psychology
professors of duke which is like my
evidence
um there's other conditioning sources as
well for instance
when you have something like google
scholar which is indexing an unknowable
number of non-academic
forum indices
you can you can get away with producing
para academic
work that's still being cited and that
satisfying
some sort of performance
indicator you know what i'm saying
so like it's not just why
also where
the imperative behind where
um
these are all like things that we
like
learn on the fly
as we're going through and
and
and experience ourselves
as shaped
by these pressures in terms of the
habits we're generating
but we never learned that
you know
[Music]
sort of uh spheres of
geo political spheres it was true for me
as an american who works in america and
like as you know but i kind of like
doesn't
think comparatively as much as i could
like it's very useful for me
well i mean
i tend to talk in the language of like
the way things are is blank but i should
be thinking the way things are in u.s
academia i'm torn though because on the
one hand it's not just uh the us but
it's also different parts
of that
i'm torn though because there is this
sort of warning that
there's this other way of doing this
that's probably coming it hasn't already
um but also uh i think
it's about navigating that space and it
could be that a lot of your approach to
doing this is a good bull walk against
that kind of
um
perceived imperative that i don't think
is imperative and doesn't always count
in your favor either by the way i've
said it on iron committees where that's
counted against people
um not in a mean way but in a
qualitative intellectual way where they
maybe put too much energy into as a judy
scholar who hasn't established itself
which is not what you're saying
but they put a little too much energy
into
a sort of non-intellectual space profile
building which means that they just
compare less favorably with people who
put their energy into really high
quality publications early in their
career for example
so anyway the whole thing's very complex
i've sort of done myself out of my
second question by talking too much and
also by this being the more charged
question but i did just want to say one
thing
about which i didn't you mentioned very
much that was implicit in what you were
saying
around
audience and i think
um
as i've thought very hard about how how
to start doing this which i've had to
promise to do as part of getting a big
grant there you go
um
random part of that is saying i will
build
x profile through x strategies or
whatever
um but as part of that thinking it's
it's not just about sort of degree of
popular rage
but also qualitatively within that are
you trying to reach a general academic
uh
uh
cut through your field in a way that
goes outside your specific area or
reach academics at live or reach
different sectors of the public too and
i think
that's not an abstract question i think
that affects things like editing choices
you know very much it starts i've
launched slightly when you cut out in
your everyday life
for example in that phrase because
for the right audience at the right
place in the in an article that could be
exactly the book that people they want
to see that word and as soon as they see
it they might sort of wake up okay i
claim i don't think they want to see the
words in your evidence i think they want
to see an example that actually reminds
them of something in their everyday life
and that would be like much more
vivid
but look we can disagree about that
particular
i don't know this is i mean wow this
stuff is like really great uh
obviously one thing is that people
you're absolutely right that like
audience is not just a number there's
like different audiences that you could
hit i compare do you know danica
mckellar you know she is
she was a she was a uh she's a very
interesting life because she was a um
a child actor
who was also like a very good uh
math major at ucla but instead of going
to grad school decided to like continue
to pursue she's an actor today but she
also like writes
a bunch of popular math books that are
like basically aimed at adolescent girls
like they're all they kind of like look
like 17 magazines like that's
that's her thing that's what comes
naturally to her that's the audience
that she knows that's the audience who's
her audience like as a tv star
um
so i sort of feel like
on some people it's good that there's a
lot of different people doing it because
people are gonna
naturally have an audience that they're
that they feel more able to speak to
and i think this comes back to you
you're thinking about communicating an
idea and selecting the right idea i mean
i think
you select the right idea for that
audience and for that forum right and
that's on you yeah it's it's you can't
squish the wrong idea into into an
audience that you know it's not
what a lot of people also want to be
exposed to stuff they don't expect i
mean that's part of what writing is all
about
i mean okay but to speak to this can i
just say your first thing
since i started with this idea that we
were going to borrow ideas that i
learned back when i thought i wanted to
be a novelist
i do think in that world
how does this play out like the world of
people who like try to write
short stories and novels and stuff and
literary fiction and stuff like that um
i think there's an authenticity
discourse
there and i do think that probably
ideally it's valued in that world
wait write the thing that you really
have to say
that's true to you and if somebody else
was like oh this person's just trying to
like
get more books in print and sell more
copies and they're sort of like doing
whatever they think will
move copies off the shelf that would be
sort of
denigrated right so i feel like this
i feel like the idea of writing for a
public audience doesn't have to false
way to valuing
profilicity
over authenticity like
and maybe you know the community that i
used to live in of literary fiction can
be
something of a model
for that
you know we have tea outside or the tea
time okay so we could uh if you want to
stop here
yes i'll take all
thank you guys so much
[Applause]